i am
so excited to be here today uh kicking
off what is going to be a fantastic week
uh so what i want to do today is is tell
you a story
of a language and like every good story
it involves a problem uh or multiple
problems so there's
some kind of dilemma my problem is that
i increasingly use web applications for
everything
uh bug tracking uh project management
even version control
but i don't use it for things like code
editing
because my code editor is completely
tricked out to be exactly the way i want
it
if it doesn't do something that i want
someone else has written some type of
plugin for it or extension
or i've written one myself i can't do
that with web applications
not yet the other problem that i have is
that i
make web applications so our company
makes these big process and workflow
heavy web applications
that regular people use to get their day
jobs done which invariably means they're
doing things that nobody ever
anticipated they would do and they have
to do this in
fairly cumbersome ways it'd be great if
they could extend those applications
or sufficiently clever user code and
then share
those extensions with other users within
the context of that application so
there's kind of an ecosystem of
extensions
for your web application this would be
fantastic
how do we do that well
we're going to need some way for people
to express functionality
and that means a language i'm an
application developer so
i mean what do i know from developing
languages right
i know nothing so let's do this the
simplest way that we can
let's use javascript we just give all of
our users access to javascript
and they can code whatever they want and
this is a great idea for
a few milliseconds until you remember
that even if there was a way to prevent
your application from devolving into
some fetid
swamp of attacks through various vectors
on other applications
you still have the problem where
users can write extinctions that that
do things accidentally like delete all
of their data if there's a bug in the
code right you really don't want that so
you need this granularity of control
but you can't really get that in
javascript it's too mutable
there's too much surface area the
language is too big
so we're going to need a smaller
language
insert appropriate boat shaped meme here
so what would that look like if we had
it
we would need to be able to create and
edit templates
since we're working on the web
specifically html but they could be
anything
we need to be able to uh extend the
functionality that the application
presents to us
ideally it's presenting this in a way
that is fairly atomic
and orthogonal so we can take these
primitives and compose them in various
ways
and uh unfortunately we're also going to
need to be able to
express interaction between ideally
modular components
that are making up our ui because we
need actual real functioning guise
which is essentially simulation
programming and everything that that
entails
okay so let's look at each of these just
briefly to see
what kind of attributes we need from
these three different languages that we
apparently need
one is that we need to be able to embed
some code in some strings
at the very least we want to embed
variable names because we don't want to
deal with c style printf statements over
long long strings that gets untenable
we can quibble about how much logic we
put in uh there's there's a big move
toward logic list templating programming
and there's a big move away from that
now
that seems to uh vary based on your
organization in my case
my designers are code compatible so i
give them huge amounts of
expressive power and they use it to do
amazing things
but regardless of our take on how much
logic should go in there we can
definitely agree that we want our
template code to be side effect free
you don't want side effects in your
templates that's a bad idea
so we also need a way to compose these
things i was going to give you a
really well reasoned argument that we
should make this a data flow language
then i realized that i there is actually
no way to argue that in a well-reasoned
way
so i'm just going to express my
preference for having this be a data
flow language
it makes a lot of sense to me because on
the server side when you're getting a
request and we want the code to run on
the server side as well
you're essentially just doing a data
transformation over something right you
get some input you do a data
transformation maybe there's a round
trip to the database you do some more
data transformation and you send it back
regardless of whether it's a query or a
command
this is what that pathway looks like on
the client side it's a little more
arguable we could have any type of
language here i like dataflow languages
partially because they maximize the
legibility so actually as the first talk
was saying
the way that we tend to read naturally
is you take some input you do something
with it you do something with it
the way that we tend to write functions
is you've got g
that calls f that calls x right so if
you're doing
function composition or if you're doing
you know g of f of x
or o of x or whatever you always end up
with the x at the end and it's kind of
backwards so if we can do this in a
stack based way or a data flow away we
get our x coming in and it feels like a
more natural read
that would be nice because these are
going to be read a lot we also need
a language for coordinating things so
ideally this would be modular
it would be reactive whatever that means
to you
uh so to me that means
um we're going to be connecting to
things from the outside those will
trigger some cascade of events
and then pass things off to the outside
again
in particular though we want this to be
limited because we don't want our
coordination between different
components to be affected by the logic
in those components we want to be able
to reason about these things at two
different levels
so we'd like to be able to look at how
things are connected and make reasoning
about that and then look at what those
things actually do and reason about that
separately so we want this separate from
the logic of our program
so here's an idea let's put them all
together
except that doesn't work because i just
said we want our coordination to be
separate
from our logic so here's a new idea
let's put a couple of them together
we'll try to stick those first two
together so we minimize the number of
new languages we have to create to solve
this problem
this slide is hard to read but
fortunately the code is not
very hard to read so you have subject
verb object
and i tend to think of this as math for
example as being some entity that is
responsible for everything mathematical
in nature
and i'm giving him a command i want him
to add some things
and those things are a couple of values
some of you are wincing because
adding two values takes 20 characters
it's
highly readable but not highly typeable
so maybe we can
do a little bit better so we're just
going to alias the words math add and
value
as the word add and essentially just
drop those in and replace it you can see
that here
so we've got pipes in this case we're
piping three
into add as one of its values we're
adding those together we get eight
we've got pipeline connectors so we we
want to be able to take a value from one
place in the pipeline and use it
multiple other places in the pipeline
uh this is the syntax for doing that it
means that the wiring in our pipelines
instead of being linear looks like a
directed acyclic graph
which is useful anything that starts
with an underscore
is effectively a static single
assignment variable
but they're not actually variable so
maybe a better word
would be good we want to embed things so
we have to wrap them in some way we're
wrapping them in curly braces
it's nice and cozy and comfortable uh
right i thought i would have to defend
this a little more wrapping everything
in curly braces but in this crowd you're
a lot of you have a lispy background so
you're comfortable with wrapping things
the thing that i do have to defend a
little bit is using lambdas that look
like strings
which is horrible
but i used to sweat over details like
this a lot and then i changed the way
the engine
worked so that i just compile everything
down to this kind of virtual machine
language and i have a virtual machine
that runs on top of
the javascript virtual machine which
runs on top of other things and so i'm
miles away from the metal
i'm in this very rare error up here
and but that means that i don't actually
have to sweat the syntax because
you can compile down to that same
virtual machine language
and have syntax that makes you happy
here's an example of string like lambdas
so we're just mapping those double
underscores at the beginning
mean take whatever the process input is
through this pipeline double underscores
later in the pipeline mean
take whatever the last segment was so
what came before the pipe
we don't usually have to use those
because we get the implicit piping
through the pipeline into the command as
we've already seen
but occasionally you want to use that
multiple
times or places in a command named
parameters i don't know if i mentioned
that explicitly
and order doesn't matter so this will
actually do exactly what you think it
will do
which is to say that if we go to
daimyo.org
which is up as of yesterday and we do
this we get
what we would probably assume we would
get
okay so the question you're all asking
can we do cellular automata the answer
is
this is almost the hello world for
programming languages in some ways
the answer is yes we can do that this is
a
three-state excitable media simulation
and
it doesn't have any uh so it's three
state but it doesn't have any state in
the sense that we're not accessing
stored state this is just kind of
traveling through the pipes and we're
not saving it anywhere
so it comes in here from somewhere
magical that i'll explain later
uh and it's essentially a list of lists
of
numbers we're going to map over that
note that we're explicitly
passing in the scope that we need inside
of this
and every time we go down a layer we
have to explicitly pass that scope in
certain things get injected into that
scope by the commands that we're using
so in this case map is going to in
addition to giving us a process input
that we'll use here to
read through one single list inside our
list of lists
so one row effectively uh it's also
going to give us underscore key and
underscore
value and we get underscore cells from
this with statement here that brings in
cells and this is another label for the
process input
this little guy looks like a primitive
that gives you a hash
it's actually just an alias like add for
math value
there aren't actually any primitives in
here so all of the functionality
is at the same level as any user level
commands that your application publishes
into the language
so once we get down inside a particular
row we're just going to switch over that
and this little bit here is going to
take
three columns out then take three or
three rows out rather and then take
three columns out so it's going to give
us in the end
a list of nine elements we'll take the
max of those
if that's equal to two then we want to
activate and go to two
otherwise we'll just stay at zero so
this is the zero state it's excitable
the other states just kind of fall off
and this is sort of a refactory state
that doesn't get excited
this is our excited state that falls to
that refractory state
so that's a little bit confusing
maybe we can actually just look at an
example and see how this works
uh so we can start this up and
we can edit the code here
and it will just kind of
live edit that which is nice
and that's horrible so let's not do
that uh okay that's better
uh so we turn the speed up and now i'm
not going to be able to get this started
am i because
it's oh good okay uh so this is just
modulating through three states this is
a five state
uh acceptable media and now we've got
all five states showing okay
so this is what the code looks like um
the part that i wanted to focus on was
right here so we can actually see this
in process this is a five state one as
you can see there's
a couple of extra states and also it's
stateful in the sense that we're
actually
storing this state somewhere
but we'll leave somewhere slightly
unspecified for now
okay okay
uh right so how do we express
interactions we saw a little bit of that
just now
but i want to back up and pretend that
you didn't actually see any of that code
that you saw
we need a language that gives us
coordination between ideally modular
components
there are a lot of ways to do this
so the there's some process calcula here
that have formal algebras for
uh kind of operating over the formal
languages that you use to describe
these uh connections of processes
and then there's other models that don't
necessarily have a formal algebra for
doing this so you
you don't get as much leverage and
showing equivalence between two networks
but in actual practice these can work
quite well
[Music]
is there anything in particular i wanted
to tell you about these
uh so
funny story about the blackboard model
no um
we'll save that for later expediency
above all else
um these process calculi and friends
vary over a large number of dimensions
those aren't necessarily orthogonal so
it's hard to
draw a chart or something of this i will
undertake that someday
but we can look at a couple of the
dimensions that they vary over and talk
about
which one we should choose based on how
these dimensions affect our
our problem and our desired goals so
mutability of network that first one uh
that just means
how is the network uh is the network
capable of changing over time so for
example in early csp
as it was first formulated i believe you
couldn't pass channel information along
channels
which meant that your network was fixed
at runtime
this gives you a lot of reasonability
about your network because you can think
about how data flows through the network
over time
and also how any components will change
in state
in a in response to that without also
having
to think about how the network changes
over time which really complicates our
reasoning
unfortunately if your process network is
distributed across a real network
that real network is going to have
partitions and you need to respond to
that
so you really do want to be able to pass
information along channels
in this case or addresses between actors
or whatever your
your process we're doing this is and
extend your network at runtime and adapt
it
so it's reasonability versus uh the
ability to respond to
events on your network uh we're going to
choose reasonability and that means that
we're
putting all of these on one single
machine
uh we can do that though because our
goal is to build gui's so we get lots of
reasonability out of our fixed network
which is great
and then these other dimensions have
similar
thought processes along them and what we
end up with is
we want to keep it local on one machine
that allows us to keep it fixed that
allows us to reason about the network
uh we're going to have unbuffered
channels and direct communication
between things and there's lots of
interesting things that fall out of this
but the
end result is that we kind of have to
make our own
up so we're going to have something that
takes
from the established work but uses it in
a slightly different way
because there isn't anything that has
the characteristics that we want
we need some safety so let's use these
components that we're using to model
our gui and our simulations and our
games
as execution spaces for the language
and attach a dialect that contains a
list of commands or functions
i call them commands
and then in that execution space that
bit of code
can only make use of the functions that
it's provided by that execution space
we also need a place to store state
obviously we're going to put that in
our execution spaces but spaces are
hierarchical
so they're nested inside each other and
so there's a question of whether you can
share or whether you have to share a
state between them you you really don't
want to and
once you do the math it turns out you
don't have to which is great so that's
nice
where does the code live so i've said
that we're executing code inside these
spaces
and we can inject that in i guess
and run it or we can have a space that
has some code in it that we execute
but we end up with a lot of problems in
coordination at that point because you
might need
multiple bits of code that run at
different times based on different input
ports
and how do you coordinate all this so
what we're actually going to do is take
our code and wrap it
in a thin wrapper that we'll call a
station
and then we'll connect this station to
other spaces that
are children of the big space that we're
in
and this would be better if i could show
you a picture but the
prototype gui is not quite up to
screenshot level yet
and then we'll link those stations which
contain code
with the spaces that contain whatever
they contain
and have a rooting network that goes
over all of this makes more sense when
you see it in practice
how do we avoid side effects so we'll
push all of the side effects everything
that connects to the outside world will
be a port from the outermost space
that we're uh implementing and
this brings up the problem of how do you
for example make a query to the database
from a bit of code
so we have a different way of rooting
those synchronous calls than we have
from rooting these asynchronous calls
which i guess i can show you instead of
telling you about
so oh we're still going over here that's
okay
so let's make a sequence um so the idea
here is we're just going to generate the
sequence of positive integers
so we just start adding numbers uh
and how does this work this is just some
window dressing
we're going to call our daimyo runtime
down here we're going to set it up build
a new space that's our outer space great
and then we've got a little bit of html
we're going to grab onto this id add one
and in particular we'll make a port here
that grabs onto it on submit and brings
a value into our space so now we can
work with that we'll route that
into an anonymous station that
does some stuff so it takes the last
value from the sequence that we're
storing a state on this space
adds one to it pokes it uh which is just
going to push that onto the end of the
sequence because we don't actually tell
it where to poke
and then we'll store that again and
we'll
trigger this thing called changed by
sending a message to it
and that's just going to be a kind of a
channel type thing that we can
push things into all it does is pass
along the value we'll pick that up down
here
grab our sequence join over it and push
that into
our div here so this is what that looks
like
uh it'd be nice if we could do something
a little more
interesting instead of just a sequence
of positive integers what if we wanted a
sequence of odds or evens or count by
10. so
here we can do that we can take some
number and add that number and this
looks very very similar this
is this is just the diffs in the code
we'll just have another form
it has an input called value down here
we're going to
link to that so we get
a message in and pull out the value
add that to the last item of the list
and then call the saver thing by pushing
a message to it and that's just going to
do exactly what we did
but in a modular way that we can also
call from here
okay
any questions at this point i'm going
fast through some things and slow
through others
yes i'm sorry i meant to do that you're
all squinting
uh yeah so this language out here that
is not wrapped in these braces
is fairly new and subject to change so i
might find ways to
pretty that up in the future and ideally
you'd be editing the code but also
looking at the graph so because this
compiles down to a virtual machine
language we can in theory
project that compilation up into both
the code that you're seeing and also
a graph that represents it that you can
actually edit so you can edit either
side
and the other side edits itself
correspondingly
that's kind of a hard problem so i
haven't solved that yet uh
but it's an interesting feature that you
can potentially get out of this
okay so what we really want to do is
have any sequence at all that we can
imagine
and so we'd like to execute code and we
can do that so
this is obviously the fibonacci sequence
we're reaching into our sequence which
is being passed in
here we're unquoting this to compile it
and then we're executing it with
a context and we're just taking the last
value and the second to the last value
and adding those together and then
if those are zero as they are when we
start we're making them one
so that gives us our boots wrapping here
this is great we can execute code but
there's a problem
because we can also do something like
this
and modify our sequence
we don't want to do that we want to kind
of force people to just add another item
on the end of the sequence and not have
access to the entire sequence itself
so that looks like this this allows us
to
keep our sequence safe so we'll add a
few things to it
and we'll try that trick again
and now we can't actually modify the
sequence value
in fact we we're not really doing
anything at all there because
we're in a different space altogether so
this is a new space that we're
embedding inside our outer space and
we're just setting up an import and an
outport
the name is doubling a support flavor
and then we've got exactly the same code
that we had before
but it's inside this other space and
we're just doing a little bit of rooting
inside that space to get it into the
station
and doing rooting on the way out so
that's great this is what
that looks like all together
i think right
good uh so that's just a
unicode histogram of the sequence to
date
this is the famous colot sequence
and i've set up a little more code here
not there
here that allows us to map the colot
sequence over this the conjecture is
that any number you start with
eventually gets to the one two four
uh loop and we can see that that is in
fact happening here
okay nice so
uh so we've shown that
we can take code and execute it and
and be safe about that in some sense
where we're not sharing state between
things but what we'd really like to see
is a more grandiose example
and unfortunately i'm going to have a
hard time doing that because
i can't connect to the network if you
can connect to the network you can go to
daimyo.org
colon 8000 and
that will get you into a turtle
simulator
and then you can tell your turtle to
move forward and turn
and if i was connected to the network we
would potentially see people doing that
here
so the idea is that we're passing code
from machine to machine
and executing that code on each other's
machines but that code only has control
over your own turtle on other people's
machines
so let me see if i can do something
local
that will at least give you the flavor
of this even if it's not
uh daimyo.org so um
oh that's local also uh d-a-i-m-i-o.org
colon8000
so there's just a little node app
running under the server there
so i can click one of these in theory
and the code shows up over here and then
i can send that and my turtle does
fancy maneuvers for me
of various kinds and ideally at least
some people
are seeing this on their machines in a
group setting but
since i can't connect i don't know if
it's actually working or not
yeah so i'm really excited about the
potential that this has
for making programmable applications and
in addition for
sharing code in particular ways so
you know one another problem that that
happens is maybe you make a game or
something
uh and maybe that game has an element
where people are kind of building out
the game world so glitch is an example
of this
and and the problem is that the more
people who play your game the more tax
there is on the server and the more
money it costs to keep all the servers
running
uh which means that if you can't
monetize your game or your tool or your
product or whatever you're making
really quickly uh it's going to go away
and everybody loses all the work that
they've put into it
what if we could flip that on its head
so that the more people who use it the
more power you have
because you're doing the execution on
the client machines and people are
actually saving that state on their
machines
and passing code around so this is what
i want to get to ultimately and i'm very
excited about that idea
these are steps in that direction do i
have time for questions